では よろしくお願いします
今日のお経文は六十二番目です
プッタ マッティ ダナ マッティイティ バーロ ヴィハンヤティ
アッターヒ アッテノ ナッティ クトゥ プッタ クト ダナ
という まあそれほど難しい言葉ではないんです
プッタ マッティっていうのは
プッタ メ アッティ 私に子供たちがいるんだよということなんですね
プッタっていうのは息子って意味なんですけど
一応子供たちまとめてプッタと言うんです
ダナ マッティっていうのは
ダナ メ アッティ ダナっていうのは財産ですね
メ 私に財産もあると 私に家族がいる
私に財産がある そういうことを考えてイティ
そのように考えて バーロっていうのは愚か者
あるいは知恵のない人々は
ヴィハンヤティ 悩むんですと
一行はそれぐらいの意味なんですけど
それでちゃんとした家族がいるならばね
それから結構財産もあるならば
愚か者と言えるのかっていう問題もありますけどね
普通考えれば ちゃんと家族がいて
そちら辺で全然何の問題もなくうまくいっている場合はね
それから収入もしっかりした収入があって
何の問題もなく悩むこともなく生きていられるならば
その人に愚か者というのはね
これは常識とは違いますけどね
世界常識では それこそ人間の素晴らしいところという風になっています
人間ならいっぱい金を儲けて
結婚して 家族を作って生活することではないかっていうのは
それが理想的な またしっかりした具体的に生きる人の世界になっています
しかし 仏教ではそれが愚か者だっていう風に
無知な人という風に言っているんですね
そこで無知な人っていうのは
財産があること 子供があることではなくて
私にいっぱいあるんだぞと自慢することなんですね
だから財産ある場合は
そう簡単に財産儲かることもできないし
親の財産を奪ってもね
管理は簡単じゃないんですよ
ものすごく大変なんです
だから欲張って財産に飛び込む人々はいるんですけど
結局は全部一文ない状態になるんですよ
自分で努力して豊かになることも結構大変でしょうし
あるいはもう何も自分でしないでも
もう親の金だけ狙っていて
親が死んじゃったら全部もう誰にも一円もあげないで
全部自分の独り占めにして
親の面倒を見る人々まで追い出しちゃって
どこから来るんですね
子供たちは親死んだら
死ぬまではもうまるっきりもうほとんど顔を見ない子供の頃出て行ったばっかりで
それで歳ぐらいになって
もう親が死んだと話を聞いたら
来て家にいる人々みんな追い出して財産は取っちゃいますけどね
でもそんな簡単には財産自分のものになりません
しっかりした管理しっかりして管理しないと
そこで現代社会ではね
家族を育てる 家族の面倒を見るということはね
もう誰も全然気にしないというかね
まあ他人任せで そんなのはどうったことはないという感じでいますけど
本当のことはそうじゃないんです
結婚生活も家族の子供の面倒を見て
子供をすくすく育てることも大変な作業なんです
だからこの 現代人みたいにね
生まれつき天才で生まれるということはないんです
子供たちは全部一つ一つ一つ一つ
道徳やら勉強やら生き方やら
何でもかんでも教えてあげなくちゃいけないし
病気になったら面倒見なくちゃいけないし
ですから この家族のことで
財産のことでも結構苦労するんですよ
だから そういう苦労はしない時代になってくるとね
すべて自動的にうまくいく社会ではわからないかもしれませんだけどね
どんな社会でもそういうわけじゃないんです
結構大変なんです そこで
そういう大変な苦労する人々はね
きちっと家族をね 何の問題もなく
もう子供なのに人殺す子供作るんでもなくて
あの立派なね 社会人になる家族を作って
親と喧嘩することもなく
仲良くして また年取った親の面倒を見るようにもなったりはする
それでえっとまあ親も収入をね
まあちゃんと確保して
しっかり管理して それから子供たちにもね
まあお金はどのように大事に使うものかとかね
どうすれば金儲かるのかとかね
そういうことも教えてあげて
まあ問題なく安らかな気持ちで死んでしまっちゃいます
ですから このここでも悩むということは
もう暇がなく大変ということなんですね
だから責任のある人に家族がいる場合は
その人には結構大変なんです
子供を育てることやらね
教育することやら まあこれかなり大変な疲れます
財産があってもまたこれまた大変忙しくて疲れるんですよ
で まあそう いうことをこちらで言ってるんですね
だから なんで愚か者かというと
何でもうちの人やというと
まあそこでもそれが人生で自分がしっかり物事を維持管理しているんだと
希望通りに大成功しているんではないかと
自分の家族を見てみなさいよと
みんな成功しているんじゃないかと
みんな親孝行しているんではないかと
親のことをすごい大事にしているんではないかと
親に向かって一言悪口言ったりとかね
喧嘩したりとか どうしようもないんだぞと
そういうふうに私はしっかり育ちましたと
私の財産見てみなさいよと
もうものすごいしっかり安定してるでしょうと
何のことなく 何の心配もなく生活できるように
もう財産はもうしっかりできてますよと
そういう まあごっつい安定した生活を作るというね
それが自分がしっかり管理してやっているんだというね
そういうところで愚か者ということを言うんですね
理由は次の行に出てくるんです
アッターヒアッタノーナッティ
自分に自分さえもいませんよと
私に家族がいるんだぞと言っていられる場合じゃないんだと
私に私さえもないんだよということは事実だよと
私には私さえもないのに
よく言うことと 私に子供がいるんだと
自分もない 自分も自分のものでないと
だから自分自身さえ自分自身のものでないにも関わらず
あんたよく言うね 財産も私にあるんだぞとかね
ということなんです クトゥクタクトゥダナンと
もう他人でしょうに 子供たちにと言ってもね
まあこの他人が自分のものになるわけじゃないでしょうし
財産というのもまた別なものでしょうに
それも自分のものになるわけないでしょうしと
自分さえも自分のものではありませんと
だからこの うまく管理してね
よく頑張って 家族の面倒を見て
よく頑張って しっかりと収入を安定して生きているんだ
これは私の努力だと だから
これは全部私のものですと
この家族も この財産も私のものだと
私が管理しているんだと
私は自分の好きなように全部やっているんだと
というふうに言えるものでしょうかと
あなたにはあなたにさえないでしょうにと
ということは もう自分のものだったら管理すればいいでしょうに
自分の命令聞くでしょうに
本当は自分さえも自分の命令わけがない
自分さえも自分にはない
何もないということですよ
初めから だから困ることっていうのは何の意味も無意味ですと
他人のものについて困ったってもね
別に まあそこら辺散歩すればかなりごっつい家とかありますけどね
もう人間にはここまで金あるのかと思うほどの家もありますけどね
それ見て ああ この家の管理どうしようか
大変だ 掃除はどうしようかとかね
ここら辺に家があるんですよ
大体人ぐらいでもいなかったら掃除できないと思いますよ
個人の家なんでゴルフ場までやります
で ちょっと散歩が歩いたらあります
だからこれ見て私は結構心配したんです
これはやっぱり人ぐらいなければ
あのそれで警備とかね
ガード そこ場所があって
家の中に入るんだけど
階段登ってそこで見張る見張り番もありましてね
それ三六〇度回るテレビカメラやらもあったりしてね
しかし警備はいませんでしたけどね
これって警備会社雇っちゃうとどうなることやとかね
だって二十四時間いない時間でしょ
そこで私は心配しなくてもいいでしょうに
人のものだからね まだ中に人間住んでるか
お化けが住んでるかまだわからないでしょうに
あれぐらいお金あるんだから人間じゃないでしょうと思いますけど
おそらく だから死んだ番所を創造した神様は日本にいるんだからね
おそらくあの人住んでるでしょうかとかね
神様だからね そんなものはこんな感じで作られるでしょうしね
だから だから だから言いたいのは人のものにね
心配しなくても どうでもいいでしょうに
心配したんだからといって
私に何の権利もないでしょうに
こうしましょう ああしましょうという一言言えるところが
もう誰がいるとも知らないんだからね
だから他人のものっていうのはそんなもので
あれ？何て言いますか
名札がないんだから誰もわからないんです
だからといってピンポン鳴らしても
そちらに住んでいるのはどちら様でしょうかと
聞こえる？聞ける？だから放っておくしかないでしょ
放っておいたんです これは自分が管理しようと思ったってもね
まあ聞いてくれるわけじゃないということで放っておいたんですけど
だから仏教というのは全部自分のものじゃないんだから放っておきなさいよと
偉そうに私に家族がいるんだぞとかね
もう会社もあるんだぞとかね
収入もあるんだぞとか
何考えてるのかと だから私は今例にいったような感じで
もうそういうごっつい財産のかたまりのようなとこ放っておけばいいんです
別に で 泥棒でも家に入ろうと思うならば
ロッククライミングを練習してないと入れません
それ壁 お城に使うものすごい二点五メートルの石畳で作ってます
そこを登ろうとすると
やっぱりロッククライミングの技法なければ登れません
かなり高いんです ですからこの
他人のものはもう 自分のものは何一つもないというと
みんな個人的には自分だからね
誰に物でもないんですよ
結局は 例えば私に私もないならばね
他のものもないでしょうに
他の方々から考えたっても私でしょうにね
だから私には私もないし
他のものもないってことだから
どんな生命にでも何もないんです
ですから まあもう一番無難は放っておくことなんですよ
しかし この放っておけない
管理するんでしょ これで当然トラブル起きますよ
もし私はあの家を管理しようとしたならば
今警察にいるでしょうね
放っておいたんだから
何のことなくこちらに来られたんです
もしそこはもう大変だ
これはすごい財産だ 管理しなくちゃとか思ったら
もうとっくにこちらには来られません
警察のお世話になる羽目になるんです
だから管理できんことに管理しようと思っちゃうと
そう簡単に行くわけじゃないんです
そういうわけで 自分のことも世間のことも
この放っておく道をね
それが正しいんだと あれ無執着と言ったっても
何も捨てるの捨ててないんですよ
仏教では 無執着 無執着の世界
無執着の心を作りましょうと
涅槃というのは無執着の心なんですよ
そうすると ああ もったいない話だとね
もったいないじゃなくて
なんかまあ気に入らないんですね
そんな捨てたらもったいないで損するんじゃないんでしょうかとかね
それよりはもうやっぱりキリスト教の方がかっこいいんだと
全部全財産自分にくれるんだから
もう富なら幸福ならもう何でもかんでも思い存分天国に行ったらあるんだそうと
もう神様待ってるんで
全部くれるために 人の希望っていうのはね
百パーセント叶ってあげるそうと
だからそういういっぱいくれることと
全部捨てなさいと言うとね
どちらにするかというと
誰でもくれる方に行きますね
ですから この捨てなさいというところで
なんか愚か者がえらく違和感というか
恐怖感というか 嫌 嫌な感じして
ブッダの教えにもう根本的に逆らうんです
それが愚か者の力で 初めからもなかったんです
何も 私は執着を捨てたって言っても
別に何か捨てるものはないんで
初めからもないんです
だから私はあの家に例え出して喋ったでしょうに
あの家見て私はびっくりしたかもしれませんだけど
初めから私の家じゃないんですあれが
家を囲んでいる壁に 壁にでも
もしかすると十億ぐらいかかると思いますよ
だからびっくりするのはいいんだけど
私は執着捨てましたと偉そうなこと言えますかね
あの家に対して 別に執着ないんだよと
初めから私のものじゃないんだから
別に ああそうですか あんたあんなすごいことを捨てたんですかねと
褒め褒めてもらう権利あるんですかね
別に一円も損失してないでしょうに
初めからも自分のものではないんです
だから 財産も自分の家族も自分自身さえも自分のものじゃないんです
だから愚か者でしょ？いい加減で言えば
あのお城みたいな 私は名前をつけましたけどね
あの現代的なお城だと
あれがお城の現代バージョンだと
だから名前つけたっても
誰も知りませんしね 私以外は
そんな権利さえもないでしょうに
でだから初めから自分でないものについて私のもの
私のもの 私のものと言うならば
これっていうのは想像を超えた愚かさなんです
だから仏教ではすごく軽々く
一般の人々には愚か者という単語を使っています
だから この偈で出てくるのは
この人生失敗した人の話じゃないんです
俗世間の考え方では大成功している人なんです
言葉がいるはもう完璧で
財産あるはもう何の問題もない
だったらもう大成功でしょ
人間というのは金があっただけで人生っていうのは満足いかないでしょうに
ビルゲイツみたいにいっぱい金があったんだからといってね
人生はどうなのかとかね
個人的にものすごい気に入っている奥さんがいて
素晴らしい子供たちがいて
でもお金がなかったらね
それでまた悩んじゃうんですよ
こんないい子たちにね
もう贅沢させてあげたい
させてあげたいんだけど
何もできないとかね こんなにすごい立派な奥さんなのに
もうアクセサリーぐらいでも買ってあげられないんだとかね
それでまた悩んだりするでしょうに
ビルゲイツさんにはね
アクセサリーじゃなくても
もう散々単価で宝石買えますけど
奥さんがいるかどうかはわかりませんね
だからこの 完璧っていうのはね
あれ あのイギリスのあのサッカー選手がいたでしょ
日本人が頭をおかしくなってたでしょ
ある時期は 何でしたっけ
あの人 名前は え？ベッカム
で みんななんか頭病気になっちゃってね
その間では結構精神科の先生たちは儲かったでしょうと思いますけど
で それからまた頭 あの
なんとかヨン様でしたっけ
それでまた頭がおかしくなっちゃって
そこっとそこっと前にあの木村さんに際しても
まあ大変 これっていうのはね
まあその場合は薬も持ちなりもらいなさいと言っておかないとね
最低お医者さんでも儲かってほしいんだからね
まあとにかくそのベッカムがね
ものすごい収入でしょ
それからあのナイトというね
あの特別な この何といいますか
貴族のあれ 称号を持ってるでしょ
だから社会では一番のトップクラス
で 奥さんも奥さんですごい美人でしょ
子供たちもね まあ結構立派な可愛い子供たちもいて
でもいろいろ問題あるでしょ
[笑い]あっちこっちで不倫したとかね
あのマネージャーとできているんだとかね
あれやこれやとかかなり大変です
ですから まあどこかでなんといくらなんでもどこかで何か問題っていうのは普通はあるんですよ
日本の小泉総理にしてもね
日本の国を完全に守ってくれるんですけど
自分の子供の面倒を絶対見ないというね
奥さんが離婚するともう妊娠している間で
だから自分の奥さんぐらいは心配してあげることの能力はないんだけど
国は守ってあげるというね
やっぱり人間っていうのは
まあそういうことで まあどこかで何かちょこっとしたものっていうのは持っているんです
何かうまくいかないところっていうのは
まあ一応あるもんですよ
もしそういう問題 何もない人がいるとしたらね
財産の世界も家族の世界という両方完璧というね
いたならばね その人に対してお釈迦様は愚か者よと言うんですよ
このアホだと なぜならば
その人は失敗さえよりも
これは私のものだと思っているんです
自分の期待通りにいってるんだから
文句をつけ所ないんだから
例えば  子供たちが離婚
結婚して独立していても
やっぱり家族みんなで一緒に
もうどこかへ贅沢なクルージングでもしたいなと思ったら
電話した途端 じゃあ行きましょうと子供たちみんな言ってくれるならばね
孫たちも連れて来るんだったら
これ最高の幸せでしょうに
これは父親がものすごいもう何千万もかかるクルージングの旅をね
まあ一応設計して予約したんだけど
あの断られたら いや 私は仕事あるんだから来ませんよとかね
あの うちの息子が学校あるんだから来られませんよとか何とか言うと
この大金持ちにとってはなんかえらく寂しいでしょうに
そういうこともなく まあ電話かけたらすぐ来て
それで 2週間ぐらいみんなでもう遊んだりして
また帰ったりとかね そういう風に贅沢な人だったらね
まあ文句つけるところもないし
何でも自分の希望通りにいくんだということにするんですよ
いくら仕事をしてもしても
なかなか収入がうまくいかないとかね
その場合はやっぱりやっぱりうまくいかないもんだなというね
気分はあるんですよ 頑張ったんだからといって
苦労したんだからといってうまくいくもんじゃないとかね
収入は足らないんだと
これ以上は時間ないんだと
仕事をしようと思ってもね
人は朝起きてもう夜 10時まで仕事をしても
もう収入が足らないんだったら
もうちょこっと他の仕事もしなくたってする時間ないでしょうに
その場合はやっぱりうまくいかないんだとね
子供は乱暴で全然言うことを聞かないで
もういい加減に不良になって
もう管理できない場合は
やっぱり自分の子供であってもね
管理できるものじゃないと
そういう大失敗者だったら
なかなか自分で管理できないと
この世の中はね は知ってますけどね
大成功者はそれ知らないんです
管理できないっていうこと
結婚したんだけど 奥さんは全然料理作らないんだったらね
今最近そういう家族っていうのは結構流行ってるでしょうね
水は触りたくないとかね
台所が汚れるんだとかね
あるいは今何て言いますか
マニキュアはかなり盛んですからね
自分の爪が汚れるんだと
ネイルアートでしたっけ
あれは 肉食動物の爪のように作るんです
いろいろ 本人には綺麗でしょうね
これ第三者が見るとね
人間の手じゃないんだからね
まあ私には相当気持ち悪いんですけどね
たまにそういう話すことがあってもね
とにかく見ない すっごくお化粧して
すごいおしゃれでブランドのものを身に着いてネイルアートまでしてくると
人間けなしたらあかん
だからとにかく見ないで
こちらにいるのは本当は人間ですと
で 覚悟してまあ話したりはする
だから一時間ぐらい喋ってもどれほど見てないかというと
またちょっとわからないんです
それでまた挨拶したりすると
いつ会ったんでしょうかと私は聞くんです
だって実は昨日 あ そう
見なかった それで思い出すんです
私は見ないと言ったら冗談じゃないんですよ
見ないんです 頭にイメージ記録しないんです
で そういうことで まあ料理できるわけないでしょう
あんな爪でね 食パンでも切っちゃうと
もう食べられなくなりますからね
だからそれで旦那がね
やっぱりどこか何か買って食べなくちゃあかんでしょ
その場合は結婚はしたんだけどね
そう自分の希望通りに行くわけじゃないというね
結論には達するでしょ
一応 そこまで喋ったのはそのためなんです
ただ うまくいかないと
希望通りには それで自分に自分もないということはどういうことですかね
初めから自分には自分がないんですよ
私たちはいくら不満を持っても
自分の体の形変えられますかね
最近はなんでか何とかありますけどね
あのプラスチックサージリーっていうやつを何て言いますか
あれは 整形 手術ね あって顎を削るわ
あれって大丈夫かなと
例えば顎がちょこっとこうなってるんだったら
これ嫌で これで手術してこれ外しても削るんです
鉄とか削るあれあるでしょ
あんなものでも削るんですよ
[笑い]で あっちこっちね
切ったり貼ったりして形を整えても
これっていうのは不自然なものだから
ずっとそのままで年取るでしょうかというね
自然な体だったら そのまんまその形でずっと維持はしますけどね
どうかなと まあそれで
まあまあそういう整形と言ったってもね
そんなに大胆なことはできるわけじゃない
例えば背が伸びてほしいんだからといってね
あの この足のね この骨があるでしょ
あの 何ですか 日本語でよくわかりませんだけどね
タイボーンというところが
これはもう切って 何か金属でも張って
またつなげて大きくする
伸ばすとか 10センチとか
これ不可能ですよ もう鼻ぐらいはね
唇とかね この上の目のね
まあそういうところはなんとかなんとかできるんですけどね
だからそういうことでも見えるのは
現代技術から見れば自分好きな体作れますよと
ある日テレビで出たんでしょ
ある女がね あの 1500回以上整形やったんだと
歳ですけど すごい若く見えるんです
それってのは自分の希望通りに行った話ですかね
結局はそういうことを見ても
希望通りにはいかないという結論なんですよ
ちょこっとした自分に気に入った他人の形をね
自分で真似るためには
もう最低 1000回の手術も考えてください
これっていいのかと それは何の証拠かというと
希望通りにいかないという証拠なんですよ
行った証拠じゃないんです
希望通りにいきましたと
だから我々はもう何とかの形で生まれる
後で鏡で見て いや こんな体嫌やと思っても
そううまくはいくわけじゃないんです
美味しい食べ物を見たら美味しいんだからパクパク食べたいんだけど
食べるとその結果 必ず体で現れる
太るのは嫌ですと 脂肪溜まるのは大嫌いですと
しかし食べたいんだと
これ成り立たないでしょう
だから希望通りにいかないんです
だから人間この苦労しますよ
男性の方々はね 髪の毛頭につけてもらうために
逃げられないために すごく苦労する
悩むでしょうし いくら悩んでも逃げるものは逃げるんでしょうね
女性になってくると もうもうケーキ食いたいわ
ソフトクリームはもう皿丸ごと食べたいわ
もうなんかどこかの品川駅にすごいごっついもうデパートあるでしょ
駅の中に それである用事があって品川に行って
帰る途中でもうすごく疲れてて
私は じゃあコーヒー一杯でも飲もうかなと
このアメリカ系レストランの店があって
そちらに行ったんです
そしたらこの気楽にいられるし
まあもう全部もうアメリカンスタイルだからね
あっちこっち嫌な顔で見るし
外人も来るし で 女性の方々は何かコーヒーに注文してるんですね
でっかい皿なんです 全部甘いものあり
これやて積み重ねて これまあもう 5人だったら食べられますけどと思ったんですけど
これ一人一人みんな注文して食べてるんですよ
だからもう女性だからね
あんまりにも綺麗に美しく
また大きくできているんだから
食いたくてたまらないでしょ
食っちゃえばそれからどうするのかと
で 歓迎を呼ばせ ずっと隣にいた女の子のそれ気になって
[笑い]もうちょっと休むから休める所なかった？で
これ女二人が女の子二人なんて来て
まあ顔を合わせて座って
二人ともでっかいデザートの皿を注文して
だからね 女性の場合はそういう甘いものを食いたくてたまらんだけど
見たらすぐ食べちゃうしね
それからまた悩むし だからそういうことっていうのは
自分の体っていうのは自分思う通りには行くものじゃないでしょうに
だから自分のもの管理できるんでしょうか？管理できないんでしょうに
それからまあ 女性には激しいんですけど
あれは何て言いますか
中年になってくると あの何障害って言うんですか
更年期障害っていうものね
これ男性にもありますけど
で 男性の場合は薄毛になるだけでね
一応あの女性の場合はそうじゃないでしょうね
すごい激しいでしょう
まあ乱暴になって 凶暴になって
ヒステリーになって もう何するかわからなくなっちゃって
もう大変なことになる
それから体はもうみるみるうちに衰えていくんですね
今まですごいスマートだったんだけど
もうひとかけらもなく消えちゃうんですね
皺が出るし それ何か何を注入したっても皺になるんですね
その更年期に過ぎてからは
だからやっぱりこれ止まることできますかね？できないでしょ
まあエストロゲン注射したりとか
あんなのをやったって
もう全く一時的だからね
一生エストロゲン注射
注射することにももういかないでしょうに
それによってまた他のどんな障害が生まれるか
も また実験も研究もデータもないでしょ
エストロゲンの体に必要な女性には特に必要なものだといってもね
自然にストップするっていうことだからね
まあ自然になくなったんだから
では注入しましょうと
それではうまくいくかどうかやってはいるんだけど
まだそこは完全安全というデータがないんです
そういうことで まあもう男性にしてもね
まあそういういろいろホルモンを使ったりすると早く死ん
発作起こして死ぬしね
そういうことなくて 自然にホルモンが減るように放っておけば
ウソになって何もやる気がなくなって
もうソファーに寝転がったままの人生になっちゃうしね
でもそれは好きなわけじゃないんですよ
本当は活発で動きたいんだけど
やっぱりソファに寝転がったらもうずっとそのままでいる
だからそういうことでね
自分の体さえも全然もう勝手
だから人の欲望に絡んだ意思は機能しないんです
体に対して では心はどうですか？それだったら自分の希望通りに動いてくれる？じゃあ何か私の説法でもこれ覚えておきなさいとか
自分の心に言ってあげてください
覚えてくれるかないかとかね
全然言うこと聞かんでしょうに
自分の心さえも なんで人生は最悪にする？全て能力を浪費する妄想してるんですかね
やめちゃえばいいでしょ
全て失敗してるのは妄想のせいでしょ
頭は全く悪いとね みんなにバカにされたりして
あんた才能なんかはもう影さえないんだよと言われるでしょうに
私はあまり遠慮しないで言いますけどね
そんなことをたとえ私が言っても
才能ないということじゃなくて
妄想するんだから 才能はもう芽生える余裕がないんです
だからちっちゃな種があっても
これは十年間握っちゃうともう死んじゃうでしょうに
もうそれでその一生 もう全く才能ゼロで生活しなきゃいけなくなっちゃう
すごい不幸でしょ？だったら妄想やめちゃえばいいでしょうに
それからこの昨日よりちょこっとインターネットで精神病の色々名前とか調べたんですけどね
もう心理学の世界ではもう病名っていうのはものすごいたくさんあります
普通のお医者さんよりはたくさん病名持っていると思いますよ
普通だったらね もう高血圧やらあれこれとかね
もうガンやらもうガンの種類によって名前を付けたりしてね
何万ぐらいもありますけど
病名っていうのはね 精神科は負けません
精神的なことにも名前を付けるは付けるは付けるは
もうもう高所恐怖症やら対人なんとかとかね
まああの普通の医者の場合は
病気っていうのははっきりした原因があって
すごい科学的なんですよ
精神科の先生いう病名っていうのは一つも科学的じゃないんです
普通にしたらあなたの頭に腫瘍があるんだから
あんたおかしいんだよと
だからこれ取りましょうと言ったら
それははっきりした科学性があって
客観性があって 論理的なものなんです
あるっていうことを調べられますからね
いろんな方法で 精神の先生があなた対人恐怖症恐怖症ですねとかね
分離症ですねとかね もうなんとかなんとかなんとかとかね
あれってあんまり具体性
論理性ある病名じゃないんです
ただ 病気で悩んでいる本人が何をやっているのかっていうことを見て
それに名前を付けてるだけ
だったら 例えば足の筋肉が弱くて
あるいは膝とか関節がうまく動かないっていうことがあって
その人は歩く場合は歩けない
それで走るとか 走るような感じでなんか飛んで飛んでいくと
お医者さんがあなたは歩く時は飛ぶ羽目になる病気ですとは言わないんです
言わないでしょ お医者さんが言うのは
あなたは関節でなんとかなんとかなっている病気ですと
それはすごい具体性があるんです
心理学の場合は あなたは歩く時は飛んで歩く病気ですって言うんです
現象を見て そこに名前をつけるんです
だって対人恐怖症といえば人を見たら怖くなるって意味でしょ
それは見える これは患者さんが訴える現象であって
例えば私はお医者さんに私のお腹
最近言いましたけどね
ものすごくお腹が痛くなるんだと
ああ なるほど あなたはお腹が痛くなる病ですとは言ってくれなかったんです
それは普通の医者だからなんです
もし精神科に行ったら
あなたはまあ あの 何と言いますか
複数病症で並んで悩んでるんだと
そういうコンプレックスだと言ってくれます
大きな補足ですけど それは本人も知ってますけど
[笑い]人を見たら怖くなる人はそれ知ってますけどね
なんで現代科学者がね
そういう風にこの非論理的な科学を作ってるんでしょうかね
だって原因がわからないんだからなんです
原因はたった一個なんです
精神病気の 妄想です 事実でないものは考えることなんです
だから ただそれだけ治せば
一万個ぐらいあの病名つけてますけど
心理学の世界ではね 全部きれいさっぱり消えます
たった一個の原因なんです
具体性が消えちゃってるんです
具体的にないものは頭の中で妄想する
だから妄想をやめちゃえば
一切の精神的な病気はすべて消えます
それからお医者さんに残るのは肉体の維持管理だけ
それってものすごくシンプルで簡単です
肉体だけなら 故障しているのは
普通の医者にしてやっても肉体だけじゃなく同時に心まで故障するんだから
治療してもしても 薬あげてもあげても効かなくなっちゃうんですね
それで 我々は自由に思考していると平気で言ってるでしょう
本当に自由ですかね？思考は
世の中何言ってます？言論の自由とか
我々の思考さえも自由じゃないでしょうに
全く他人のものでしょ？結局は
それぞれの人の心 何考えているのかということはね
その本人にも管理できないんです
だから自分に自分もないんです
あの隣にあるあの家と同じなんです
あれは私には何もできません
見てびっくりしてたんですけど
[咳]だからお釈迦様が言うのはそういうことなの
自分に自分もないんだからね
これ私の財産やと言うなよと
これが私の家族やとよく言うもんだと
この芸の意味はそういうもので
だからまあシンプルなんですけど
またかえってブッダの言葉だからね
もうごつごついです すごく真理そのものを何のことなくおっしゃっているんです
だから世間ではもう知られている真理じゃないんですね
世間は全部自分が我が輩は管理しているんだぞと思っているんです
我々にはもう自分の心の管理もできん
心は勝手で 肉体の管理もできん
肉体は肉体の勝手で なのにしっかり子供管理するんだと
それっていうのはありえないんです
財産管理すると これ一つもありえないんですよ
成り立たないんです だからうまくいくためには
自我ではなくて このあらゆる原因を考えて考えて
この原因条件をあれこれやと合わせるしかないんですよ
一応成功している人々はそれをやってます
子供にあんたしっかり勉強しなさいと言ってもうまくいくわけじゃないんです
そこでいろいろ考えて
原因を調べて どういう原因があったらこの子の子は勉強にやる気を出してくれるのかどうかね
勉強が面白いと思ってくれるのかどうか
そういうことを考えて
そういう原因を揃ったりする
それで結果として勉強にやる気を出してくれたりはする
そこで原因を揃ってあげることはうまくできたら結果も出てくるだけのことなんですよ
太るの嫌だなと思っている人であるならば
どういうわけで太るのかとかね
痩せる原因は何なのかとかね
そこは徹底的に調べて
その原因を揃ってあげる
原因を揃ってあげたら体勝手に痩せる
私が痩せましたではないんです
私が痩せまっただったらすぐ今痩せればいいでしょうに
だから私がやりました
これは私のものということが極端な無知な思考で
無知のトップなんです
数学できないっていうのは無知とは仏教は思わないんです
科学はもう全くできなくて
理解もできなくて その勉強をやめたと
あんた頭が悪いと仏教では言わないんです
それには 仏教の無知っていうのは別なものなんです
なぜならば 科学勉強できない人にとっては別なものいくらでもありますからね
学校の勉強は全部できない
もう気に入らない ダメという子にしたっても
他やることありますからね
一人前になるためには
だから勉強できないという意味じゃないんです
学識ないって意味じゃないんです
学問があっても頭がいいってわけでもないんです
学問がすごくできた人でも
えらく私がという感じになるでしょう
結局はかえって結果としては
私がその分野については日本の権威だそうと
言うともとんでもない愚か者で一人医者がいたでしょ
能力はもう世界的だ 抜群で
でも結局人殺しちゃったんだから
ネズミ処理しなかった
結核なんですかね エイズの
日本人何人かにエイズつけちゃって
それでも狂暴でしたから
あの教授が 彼から勉強した人々をものすごく怖がったりしてね
その先生は怖いと 何のことない
ただの狂暴だけだと思いますけどね
ちょこちょこと勉強できちゃって
もう大学の教授になっただけのことで
まあ高慢で学生さんのね
もう緊張ばっかりして勉強しているお医者さんたちをね
もうとことんいじめたい放題いじめたりして
そこで自分の馬鹿なアホらしさバレたらまた帰って狂暴
まあなんか逃げたみたいですね
もう亡くなったかな わからないんですけどね
だからそういう方々は本当はバカじゃないんでしょうね
もう本当にすごい能力ある
もう俗世間ではもうしっかりしたですが
仏教から見れば相当な愚か者なんですね
かなり相当ですよ なぜならば
勉強が徹底的にして権威になったら
みんなその人に頼っているでしょうに
政府にも 学問というのは原因を調べることだからね
もっと真剣に もっと真剣に
もっと真剣にするのは普通知識人のやり方なのに
これがもう勝手にいろいろ決めたりして
データもごまかしたりして
ですから ただ頭が良くて勉強できて
日本の権威になったと言ってもね
それで知識人というか
理性のある人ということを仏教では見ないんですね
かえって俺がという気持ちになると
これが愚か者なんですね
私がやっているんだと
だから私がやっているということは一つもあるわけじゃない
我々は今まで生きているのも自分でではないんです
何とか現金揃ってあげる
そこで自然にそういう結果が出ているだけ
で 何かもう野菜を作ることと同じなんですよ
種をまくんであって 自分には芽を出すということはできないんです
一応土の上で種をまいて
必要な条件を揃ってあげたら
そちらそちらの勝手で芽を出したりして大きくなったりはする
大きくなったんだからって
全て自分の期待通りに行くわけじゃないでしょうに
たとえキュウリ作っても
もう出来上がっちゃう
キュウリ全て売り物にならないでしょうに
一つのつるに例えば本ぐらいキュウリができても
本も取って はい もう店に出すということはできないんです
店でもいろいろ条件があるんだからね
形そろえなくちゃいけないは
長さそろえなくちゃいけないは
とかね だからやっぱり自分の希望通りに行くわけじゃないんです
で 日本のきゅうりはかなり大きくなるんですよ
まあこんな感じで それぐらい大きくなるとすごく美味しいんです
でも見たことないでしょう
栄養入る前に食べなくちゃいけないという決まりがありますからね
なんでももう私はこのプルーンほどまずい果物ってあるのかと思っていたんですよ
店にあるプルーン食べちゃって
こんなまずい果物って
それで日本でどこかでプルーン作ってるところに何か用事があって行ったんですね
言ったら まあもうずっとその固定概念で
プルーンっていうのはなんか間違って現れた果物で
これがまずいと その家でもうプルーン作っていて
もうだから全然売り物にならなくて
デパートに出せないんだと
だから捨てる そういうものはもうたくさん座ってた食卓のところに
ちゃぶ台ですか まああったんですね
そしたら私はまあしゃべりながら食べてみたんです
びっくりしちゃったんです
これ何や？と聞いたんです
そんなあまりにも美味しくて
そしたらプルーンです
それで今までの固定概念どうするのかと
それで考えたら なんでこんなにすごく美味しくてね
お腹いっぱい食べたって満たされないぐらいすごい美味しかったんです
一個食べたらもう半年間十分やと思うプルーンと
この差は何なのか聞いたんです
聞いたら いやあの それはあの店に出す場合はもうこういう条件がありまして
ということでね だからそういう条件に揃わない自然なものは売れないんだと
それでなるほどと 一つ勉強になったんです
デパートの品物は食べるものじゃないと
でもずっとそればっかり食べてるんだからね
まあ全然気づかないんですけどね
だから結局は我々の希望通りじゃないんでしょうね
で 買うお客様もすごい頭がいいんだから
形だけ揃っていれば それが何かあのビニールのあれ
何か袋に入れて それからまたなんとかちらちら細い何かもうスポンジみたいなもの上で
また綺麗な箱にして まただったら買うと
二百円では絶対買わない
二千五百円でなければ
で そういうことだから
そういう品物を出さなくちゃいけない
どうせもう二千五百円で買ったものだから
美味しくないと思ってもらわないとね
買った人は悔しいんだから
これは美味しいっていうことに決めておく
だからもう何やと心っていうのはね
思いますけど それでまあ何一つも我々の希望通りには行くものじゃないんです
例えば本当にきゅうりは言うほど美味しいなのかと思っても
皆様にはどう頑張っても手に入らないでしょ
もう取りたければ それを作っているところに行って
お願いしますから これは取らないで放っておいてくれませんかと
お願いしてもらわない限り
あるいは自分で作って早く取らないで放っておかない限りは食べられないんでしょうね
やっぱりそれでも自分の希望通りじゃないでしょ
それもその原因 因果法則に沿って行動しなくちゃいけないんです
だから あるのは因果法則というものなんです
ないのは自分なんです
それ分かればもう知識人なんです
俗世間なレベルでも 一般の人よりは知識人なんです
仏教から見れば智慧のある人なんです
心配することはない その人は失敗しない
悩んだり苦しんだりもしません
ないのは自分 あるのは因縁法則
あ それで一応終わりますけど
[紙の音]